>>Narrator: At a small school
in rural south Georgia,
teacher and IT director, Vicki,
uses every kind of technology
to connect her students to the world.
>>Vicki: And then you have to put a
hyperlink to your Google doc, okay?
>>I blog at the Cool
Cat Teacher blog,
which has about six thousand readers.
It just won the Edublog award
for best teacher blog
in the world this year.
And I've traveled a bit,
talking about what we're
doing, but I teach full time.
That's my focus.
>>What are some of the things
that you have learned how to do
that you think are very interesting?
>>I believe every student can
learn, every child can learn,
but where children have trouble
is when you have only paper,
and only pencil, then
only certain types
of children are going to succeed.
>>Who's the avatar team?
Raise your hand.
You? Okay, Tuesday, the
avatar team is teaching.
>>I don't have to be
in front all the time.
I need to look for rich experiences.
I like to call myself
a teacherpreneur.
I'm looking at the students I have.
I'm looking at their
strengths, their interests,
and I'm accomplishing the curriculum,
but I'm customizing what happens
in the classroom according
to that group of students.
>>You have to click on object
and change your X, Y and Z.
>>I focus on teaching them
how to learn new software.
Learning how to learn, using the
Wiki, how to blog effectively,
collaborating effectively,
being very comfortable
with just about any technology.
>>On our class Wiki-- everybody
remember where our Wiki is?
You're going to go to the
class Wiki and make sure
that I have a link
to your Google doc --
>>A lotta times I use new
terms, and I expect them
to Google it and look it up.
That's a literacy-- you know, how
do I find new terms and look it up?
I don't have to define
everything and I shouldn't.
They should be thinkers.
>>Have you all brainstormed
some ways?
You have about another
minute and a half or two.
You all brainstorm some
ways that you can use this
to teach digital citizenship.
>>In this class, students are
learning a virtual life program
called Open Sim by
helping to teach it.
>>Student: So you're all
allowed to come to me.
>>Vicki: So many teachers think that,
I need to know everything
before I teach it,
and that is absolutely
the wrong thing to think.
Because you think about the
empowerment these students have
when they find out and
they figure it out.
>>Student: Pull up your mini--
>>Vicki: Look at what
they did in three days.
They changed their avatars.
They learned to terraform.
I did not teach the terraforming
group how to terraform.
They were teaching me.
I literally didn't know how
to terraform until today.
It's just phenomenal.
>>Narrator: Davis and Julie
Lindsey, a teacher in Qatar,
founded the global
collaborative project, Digi Teen.
Students from around the world
studied digital citizenship
by researching, writing
and posting their work
through two digital portals.
On the Digi Teen Wiki,
students post their research
and writings on assigned topics.
>>Vicki: And you all, I don't mind
if you grab the information
off of there to link--
>>And on the Digi Teen
social network, teachers
and students connect,
blog and share ideas.
>>Virginia: The most recent blog
I'm very proud of is the rights
and responsibilities blog that
I did with like so many people
from around the world on Digi Teen.
>>Davis and Lindsey also created
the Flat Classroom project.
>>Vicki: The Flat Classroom
project lets the students study
and experience the trends
in information technology,
by collaboratively writing
reports with other students
and creating videos where they
have to outsource part of it
to the other students, so they
experience the trends and learn
about the trends with
students all over the world.
>>In January, 2009, Davis and
several of her students traveled
to the Middle East to attend
the Flat Classroom Conference.
>>Betty: We're in a rural setting.
I mean, we're in south Georgia, about
as rural as you can get, but yet,
she has got us connected to the
world, and she has got our children,
who are basically rural children,
with a whole new perspective
of possibilities, of
what's out there.
>>Vicki: I believe this whole idea
of sorta turning school upside down
and empowering students
to share with one another.
If you can empower them, you're just
going to have a better classroom.
>>Okay.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org